[Music] Maybe the
slots were suddenly filled I
didn't pretend to be the rest of the military fund and handed it over
No, that's not the
case.  It
's a party I'm
happy every day I'm
cured of my illness and I'm popular
What is this?
Recruiting only for food would be tough.At
this rate, no one will come.In
general, you may be a high-class food, but I'm the weakest.
[Music]
This ocean trench was chosen by the world and I
waited for the appearance of people like you
Megumin Archquisar made a living and wielded the
strongest attack magic and
explosion magic.  The
story of a girl and her friends, also known as the Great Wizard and the Explosive Wizard A
new adventure begins now
[Music]